Yeah, I was about to.
NOTE CONF
Very interesting.
Both sides want to go.
NOTE CONF
Oh, my God.
V?
NOTE CONF
Yes, it is.
Touch it up.
NOTE CONF
I take them out, which is and you can then
right.
NOTE CONF
You can put it in like thank you, or you
have to do this.
NOTE CONF
I don't know if it five.
Hey, OK, they got in.
NOTE CONF
Spend some time to look at what day?
Seems like a and you break.
NOTE CONF
That means nothing.
People attach it to just randomise stuff that they wanna
NOTE CONF
do for you guys.
That's fine.
NOTE CONF
But in the day someone says you need to you
they probably don't know the you know how you gotta
NOTE CONF
look for those little clues to tell you the person
you're talking to is just kind of full of crap.
NOTE CONF
That's one of them.
Alright, let's go.
NOTE CONF
905.
I might be sitting down a fair bit today, cos
NOTE CONF
we've got some typing to do.
I don't know.
NOTE CONF
We'll see.
Uh, I should put this on, but to my to
NOTE CONF
the people online apologies.
If the voice goes up, down, in out because of
NOTE CONF
the different mics doing their different thing, it's just the
way they roll.
NOTE CONF
Um if anyone out there is watching.
The online stream wants to report when there are problems.
NOTE CONF
Feel free.
I won't try and do both.
NOTE CONF
And so that's a reminder for our folks online in
Com 3000 com Online lectures are not a first class
NOTE CONF
experience.
A, uh, a backup, Um, and so if you're watching
NOTE CONF
online, you might not get your question answered.
If you need questions answered, come in.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it's really mostly there for the recording, but, you
know, maybe someone in the hall here is watching the
NOTE CONF
online stream and can help you out on the comments.
Maybe not.
NOTE CONF
No guarantees, but it's just not possible for me to
teach a class and follow the online stream closely enough,
NOTE CONF
uh, to make it work.
OK, Does anyone have any questions?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Ah, And so implicit in that is that that most
NOTE CONF
of you are online watching 200 people or 2468, 1012.
Alright, so let's just over 5% of students turning up.
NOTE CONF
Uh, like I'm trying not to be judgmental, and that's
important, right?
NOTE CONF
You you do what you do with your life.
Um, but there does come a point where the whole
NOTE CONF
lecture thing breaks down.
So for those of you online who are wondering if
NOTE CONF
you're thinking of coming in, Definitely.
Do try and make it worthwhile.
NOTE CONF
I think we make the lectures an experience worth doing.
Um, and we don't use the whole three hours.
NOTE CONF
We normally just use two hours I'm pondering.
Well, no, I probably can't do that.
NOTE CONF
I'm hoping I'm wondering if I can switch the start
phone back to 10.
NOTE CONF
Cos we only ever used the two hours anyway.
Um, but we'll keep that one in the bank.
NOTE CONF
OK, This week is especially fun week because we're just
learning two new languages.
NOTE CONF
Easy learning languages is what we're here for.
It's my favourite thing.
NOTE CONF
I've learned thousands of them.
Millions of them.
NOTE CONF
No, maybe not millions, but definitely hundreds.
And today we are learning locks and ruby locks is
NOTE CONF
a made up language.
Ruby is an important language, and we're also gonna do
NOTE CONF
a bit of machinery to make sure that you've got
the development environment you need on your computer and a
NOTE CONF
bit of admin because we've got this assessment coming up.
OK, so 3000 this year we'll start with the assessment
NOTE CONF
3000.
This year is an early kind of assessment just to
NOTE CONF
make sure everybody's up and running well.
We've always had an early assessment, but it used to
NOTE CONF
be an assessment on Scala so that we could make
sure people knew how to programme Scala before we moved
NOTE CONF
into the more advanced stuff.
Um, this year, it's it's really a catch-up on Java
NOTE CONF
to make sure that you, uh, remember all the stuff
we taught you about Java.
NOTE CONF
But it's also the task we've given you is very
closely related to what we're learning and something that people
NOTE CONF
tend to struggle to pick up.
So it's a stand alone interpreter that you're supposed to
NOTE CONF
write everything you need to know about it and the
way we've described it, you can just do with Com
NOTE CONF
1010 material.
Um, we've asked you some things from Comp 2000 about
NOTE CONF
Landers, and I ask you about exceptions.
No, just Landers, maybe, uh, for some further marks.
NOTE CONF
But the point I want to make is that you
don't have to be reading ahead on the book to
NOTE CONF
answer this question, but it's very closely related to where
the textbook goes.
NOTE CONF
We picked a super simple language where the old ideas,
if you just think hard about it, you can solve
NOTE CONF
the problem with those ideas in the textbooks, the locks
language is much harder when you have the new ideas
NOTE CONF
to learn how to process that.
And so we're actually writing an interpreter straight away, which
NOTE CONF
is the whole point of the course, but a super
simple interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Well, an interpreter that you can do just with your
current knowledge.
NOTE CONF
And hopefully that gets you thinking about some of the
problems that come up with doing interpreters, gets you heading
NOTE CONF
down the right track and also double checks that you
know how to do your Java programming double checks that
NOTE CONF
you've got your development environment set up, double checks that
you're ready to roll.
NOTE CONF
You know, just sitting there staring at us, Blankley.
OK, so, um, I just wrote draughts so that if
NOTE CONF
any questions come up today, I can include those in
there before I finalise it tomorrow or today.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but we're writing a string expander, and it runs
like an interpreter, and we're gonna look at some more
NOTE CONF
interpreters today, so you understand more strongly what that means,
But the specifications up there.
NOTE CONF
Let's take a look.
Let's have a go.
NOTE CONF
And it's due very soon.
So we've gotta get going quickly on this one.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I did say, uh I think I said
somewhere reading ahead might be useful.
NOTE CONF
But the more I think about it, the more I
think, actually, probably writing this from scratch might be better.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I took that away.
Um, yeah.
NOTE CONF
So just sit down and work your way through this
problem.
NOTE CONF
Write it up.
The rubric currently includes an item about, um, your solution
NOTE CONF
being unique.
I'll just talk through that as well.
NOTE CONF
Uh uh, There it is.
It's got this uniqueness one down the bottom.
NOTE CONF
I'm pondering whether we keep that or or swap that
out.
NOTE CONF
So what's this, hippo?
We're in this middle ground at the moment these days
NOTE CONF
where there's a lot of online material that you use
to, um, inspire your work, right.
NOTE CONF
And that's kind of fine if you wanna be a
past student, and you wanna, um, use online material and
NOTE CONF
just cobble it together and you kinda understand what's going
on.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, OK, fine.
But we also want to reward people who just go
NOTE CONF
straight out of their own head and get it down
on the paper.
NOTE CONF
We wanna de we wanna give them more marks cos
they're demonstrating a greater mastery.
NOTE CONF
And so one of the ways we've tried to do
that is by putting in this kind of rubric item
NOTE CONF
where you know we're we're getting into plagiarism territory here,
but it's a bit bit of a combination of the
NOTE CONF
two.
It's like, Alright, if you just copied off someone, then
NOTE CONF
you shouldn't get marks.
But also, if mostly it was just a cobbled together
NOTE CONF
section of things that were online or the things that
other people did.
NOTE CONF
Maybe that's also not marks because it's not demonstrating your
knowledge.
NOTE CONF
Um, so I guess what I'm saying is that I'm
open to discussion and that people have discussion with me
NOTE CONF
today because as academics, we're in this middle ground where
we're like, Well, I could just take that line off
NOTE CONF
and just send people off to academic integrity if they
get caught submitting someone else's code or online code.
NOTE CONF
Or I could put that in, and I'm less likely
to have to do the academic integrity, but I'm likely
NOTE CONF
to to catch more people because it's just a rubric
item.
NOTE CONF
I'm being more generous in what counts.
As you know, I'm not looking for actual plagiarism.
NOTE CONF
I'm just looking for similarity as an indication that it's
right that it's been heavily inspired by elsewhere rather than
NOTE CONF
coming from the student zone her mind.
So just keep that in mind if you want to
NOTE CONF
talk to me about that, Uh, well, if you don't
talk about that now, you can.
NOTE CONF
But you can also talk to me about that offline.
Let me know your opinions on that kind of rubric
NOTE CONF
item because, uh, yeah, especially in these days we are.
Yeah, in in between and betwixt.
NOTE CONF
So we don't have a clear direction either way.
And both solutions are fine.
NOTE CONF
Just got really pick which of those fine solutions we
prefer to go with.
NOTE CONF
OK, um but you can see in the rubric the
kind of things we're gonna, uh, ask you to do,
NOTE CONF
but quick, java programme.
Off we go.
NOTE CONF
Um, I'll probably provide a demo script as well in
the rubric.
NOTE CONF
Uh, sorry.
In the specification, I've got a few examples of what
NOTE CONF
the interpreter has to do, but I'll probably provide some
more as well before the end of the day.
NOTE CONF
Uh, probably provide a full script of me working with
my solution interpreter, putting various strings in and getting various
NOTE CONF
things out that you can look to for inspiration, No
question.
NOTE CONF
Good.
Ok, well, maybe I will look online for a second,
NOTE CONF
because I'm gonna ask you.
And sometimes people prefer to put their answers online.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I'm in student view, so I'm not saying what
I expect.
NOTE CONF
It's just quickly.
People sometimes like to write, write answers in the chat
NOTE CONF
instead of what?
A man.
NOTE CONF
Hyperlink.
A new tab doesn't work.
NOTE CONF
People breaking the web.
Very frustrating.
NOTE CONF
Um, and anyway, so what I want to ask you
guys is is what what an interpreter is?
NOTE CONF
We spoke a little bit about it last week, but,
you know, an actual concise definition of what an interpreter
NOTE CONF
is would be a nice thing to have, because I'm
about to ask you Well, I've just asked you to
NOTE CONF
write an interpreter.
Does anyone have a definition what an interpreter is?
NOTE CONF
And it can just be whatever comes into your head
when I say that word.
NOTE CONF
Because half of my reason for asking you is not
to get the right answer.
NOTE CONF
It's to get where you're at Anybody.
Yeah, um, execute instructions, executes instructions.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, absolutely.
So that's definitely true.
NOTE CONF
How is it different from a programme?
A programme will execute instructions.
NOTE CONF
Right.
What makes an interpreter separate from any other programme?
NOTE CONF
And it suffered as read instructions.
Reads instructions.
NOTE CONF
Dynamically.
Yes, that's a really good way to look at it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so yes, it's executing instructions, but it's getting them
dynamically.
NOTE CONF
They're not preset in a file somewhere.
Wait a roll.
NOTE CONF
So, on that definition, if you could send instructions to
your CPU one at a time, it would be an
NOTE CONF
interpreter as well, just an interpreter for a very, very
simple language.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, the the the clearest example people have of
interpreters that they might have used in the past are
NOTE CONF
the the consoles on their games.
Like Minecraft is the one I know about, right?
NOTE CONF
You bring up the console and you can put in
commands one at a time, and the computer will interpret
NOTE CONF
them and do what they say.
It'll teleport people or chuck people or whatever.
NOTE CONF
People one at a time give an instruction.
It does what you ask and sometimes reports back some
NOTE CONF
information.
That's it.
NOTE CONF
That's an interpreter.
So that can be super simple.
NOTE CONF
The instruction can just be the instruction can be trivial.
But when the instructions that we're giving the interpreter, uh,
NOTE CONF
written in a programming language, that's when we've gotten into
what we would call as programming language, people, interpreter territory.
NOTE CONF
So what you're gonna see in this assignment is that
what we've given you doesn't really qualify as a programming
NOTE CONF
language, but it's getting in that direction and you're creating
the interpreter of machinery that says, Give me, Give me
NOTE CONF
some information.
I will do something.
NOTE CONF
Give me the information again.
I will do something.
NOTE CONF
Give me the information again.
I will do something and our book is called Crafty
NOTE CONF
Interpreter.
So it's obviously important to us.
NOTE CONF
You and I brought that up just in case anyone
typed it there.
NOTE CONF
A lot of answers.
So this week we have, um so that's the admin
NOTE CONF
on our machinery.
I'm gonna show you the the Dev environment that we're
NOTE CONF
using that we didn't get to last week.
So we're using straight java here.
NOTE CONF
Most of you probably have java on your machines which
means you can just do most things directly on your
NOTE CONF
machines.
But I'm gonna show you my dev setup, which is
NOTE CONF
the one I'm gonna encourage you, uh, to use for
a couple of reasons.
NOTE CONF
One is that it's a great General Dev setup, but
also it gives you access to all the other languages
NOTE CONF
we're playing with which you probably don't have installed on
your machine.
NOTE CONF
Most of them are relatively easy to install, but OK,
One of the big problems as a developer is that
NOTE CONF
normally you're using a huge range of tools.
You're using different versions of tools.
NOTE CONF
So this is happening to me right now.
Comp 3000 is being taught in Java 12 com 2000
NOTE CONF
is being taught in Java 21.
So I need to have both Java installed on my
NOTE CONF
machine, actually not a giant issue with Java.
But if you're teaching Python and you've got to teach,
NOTE CONF
uh, well, actually, it happens with python all the time.
Most operating systems these days Mac os for sure.
NOTE CONF
Linux, for sure have a system python that they U
that's used for a lot of system tools and that
NOTE CONF
if that version changes your operating system dies because if
there's some incompatibility between the python version installed and the
NOTE CONF
Python version expecting operating system level things stop working.
So on Mac and Linux, there's a python in there
NOTE CONF
that you should never touch and upgrade.
You gotta leave that to to the operating system vendors,
NOTE CONF
so you should be installing your own python next to
it.
NOTE CONF
And if you're a python programming, you know you use
virtual environments for that.
NOTE CONF
And you know it's a bit of a hassle, and
the same thing gets repeated over and over for every
NOTE CONF
language and the issues that come up in having multiple
versions is is the dependency hell you might have heard
NOTE CONF
of before.
One version is dependent on this library.
NOTE CONF
The other version is dependent on a different library.
The two libraries can't coordinate, so it's It's just generally
NOTE CONF
a nightmare, so programmers have all kinds of ways to
get around that I always use the development container approach,
NOTE CONF
and so I'm gonna run you through that because it's
what we've got set up for you, if you need
NOTE CONF
it.
And I just generally encourage you to follow the Dev
NOTE CONF
Container approach.
The development container.
NOTE CONF
So how does the development container work?
Well, first of all, I'll actually we've given you the
NOTE CONF
files up here.
That's what this, uh, random thing was in the unit
NOTE CONF
description.
That's for your own setup.
NOTE CONF
And here's how it works.
First of all, your machine needs to have a docker
NOTE CONF
server running.
So what docker is is it's kind of a lightweight
NOTE CONF
virtual machine thing that sits in the background of your
computer.
NOTE CONF
It burns resources.
So if you've got a low end computer, don't worry.
NOTE CONF
Don't go down this route.
It's not for you.
NOTE CONF
It burns resources because it's spinning up lots of mini
virtual machines for you.
NOTE CONF
We have a quick look at my docker.
Um, it's currently got all these virtual machines available.
NOTE CONF
It's only running one of them at the moment.
Um, and that's the open JDK 11 1, because I'm
NOTE CONF
currently running like, 3000 stuff, so a a whole separate
tool.
NOTE CONF
But you need, uh, that you might choose to use
docker by itself, and that's fine.
NOTE CONF
You might already know about docker by itself.
But I'm not showing you that I'm showing you what
NOTE CONF
VS code provides and so you don't actually think have
to think too hard about the Docker.
NOTE CONF
You can just do S code So you should all
be familiar with VS code.
NOTE CONF
Anyone not used VS code Good VS code is our
development environment that we're using And a key advantage of
NOTE CONF
VS code is that if you put these two file
or this file here the Dev Container file inside the
NOTE CONF
dot dev container directory it will use it will run
all of your code inside a docker container instead of
NOTE CONF
directly on your machine.
So this file tells visual studio code which docker container
NOTE CONF
which is a virtual machine, which virtual machine to go
and fire up.
NOTE CONF
When I'm working on this code and the console that
I have down here, the terminal is actually in that
NOTE CONF
virtual machine.
It's not on my Mac.
NOTE CONF
So if I do LS slash on here, I'm seeing
a Linux file system, not my Mac file system, because
NOTE CONF
Docker has virtualized everything for me and all my work
is being done in that and the docker images you
NOTE CONF
get are always Linux images.
Docker is only built for Linux.
NOTE CONF
So once you're inside those, you're just doing standard Linux
stuff, So that's also nice.
NOTE CONF
It doesn't matter which machine I'm on a windows machine.
A Mac machine.
NOTE CONF
They're the only ones it runs on.
I can't run it on a chromebook, but the the
NOTE CONF
little console I'm getting is what I expect.
It's Linux based.
NOTE CONF
And so I have, uh, portable knowledge there.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
There's extra install script attached to this one because, um,
this is how we install all of our separate libraries.
NOTE CONF
That's not a necessary part of the docker.
But I think I've given you all three Dev Container,
NOTE CONF
Dev Container, Jason and Install because you can see the
Dev Container.
NOTE CONF
Jason also runs the install script.
So what this means is, when you first do this,
NOTE CONF
you're actually installing a whole new operating system running an
install on it.
NOTE CONF
It takes a little while, uh, but VS code looks
after you there, but once you've done it once on
NOTE CONF
your local machine, VS code keeps track of that docker
image, and it just spins it back up again every
NOTE CONF
time.
So it's faster.
NOTE CONF
And the only trick is that instead of just opening
your code like normal, you will open it normally and
NOTE CONF
then you'll ask Docker, uh, various code, please, to, uh
Well, that's reopen folder locally.
NOTE CONF
I can't see re I can't see the one I'm
expecting, um, already in the container.
NOTE CONF
But normally, if you can bring up a command and
it'll say reopen in container because if you just open
NOTE CONF
the directory, it's on your local computer, Then you ask
it to reopen it in the container, and it does
NOTE CONF
that once it's done that you can see down in
the bottom left.
NOTE CONF
But you're running inside a container now, um, Com 3000
at desktop Linux.
NOTE CONF
So I know that I've got Linux down here, so
I encourage you all to do that.
NOTE CONF
And this is all my, uh, comp 3000 stuff, including
a bunch of stuff you can't see yet shouldn't see
NOTE CONF
because it's got solutions and things, But it's everything.
It's my comp 3000 and so I can do anything
NOTE CONF
I need to down here.
Now I'm doing I.
NOTE CONF
I do a lot of things by hand, and I'm
gonna show you all the by hand so we're not
NOTE CONF
gonna be pressing build buttons to automatically do build scripts.
We're gonna be knowing what the build script actually does
NOTE CONF
doing it ourselves.
Uh, so let me start you with my first build
NOTE CONF
script.
Right now, we're not actually into the Java site.
NOTE CONF
We're learning locks today, which is the language that the
interpreter defines.
NOTE CONF
But I have downloaded all of Nystrom S code and
compiled it so that I can provide to you a
NOTE CONF
locks interpreter to play with.
Otherwise it just if you've read the book, you're just
NOTE CONF
reading the book and you're like, Well, OK, that's good.
But now what if I wanted to try it?
NOTE CONF
You need to actually compile a lock interpreter.
Well, he provided one, and I've done that, and I've
NOTE CONF
made it available for you.
It's also been compiled and set up so that we
NOTE CONF
can use it in Code Runner So we can potentially
ask you locked questions through Code Runner uh, which is
NOTE CONF
why it's stuck on Java 11 because that's what code
run is stuck on.
NOTE CONF
So as long as you've got a version of Java
later than Java 11, it should be fine.
NOTE CONF
But if you've got a java eight or a java
nine, you'll get that weird class mismatch error.
NOTE CONF
So please, you just should at least upgrade to travel
11.
NOTE CONF
That's not too bad.
And if you use the the docket image, you'll get
NOTE CONF
the the high one questions on that that all makes
sense.
NOTE CONF
So I do want you to spend the time to
make that work.
NOTE CONF
Please.
Ah, now another.
NOTE CONF
Now, for those of you who don't have computing power,
uh, there's a backup option here, which is really nice
NOTE CONF
if you put your code up on github.
Keep it private repository.
NOTE CONF
Cos you'll probably have solutions to assignments up there if
you put it up on github.
NOTE CONF
Um, so where's some?
I don't have this code on github, but let's say,
NOTE CONF
uh, this code on github any code on github that
includes this dev container slash dev container stuff.
NOTE CONF
When you click over the the code button, you get
the option to code in a code space.
NOTE CONF
Uh, you've only got a certain number of three hours
on github, but it's might be enough for the course.
NOTE CONF
If not, you can just pay for some more.
It's cheaper than buying a computer.
NOTE CONF
Um, is there one I've got going already?
Um, maybe this one?
NOTE CONF
No.
All right.
NOTE CONF
We'll just start one from scratch.
I'll try and pick an easy one.
NOTE CONF
You press the create code space on main, and it
spins up a docker image for you on the cloud
NOTE CONF
gives you the VM the visual studio code, just like
as if it was on your local computer.
NOTE CONF
So the code space.
If you don't have the power to run all of
NOTE CONF
this on your own computer, you can use a github
code space or you can use a GI pod, which
NOTE CONF
is a another company doing the exact same thing.
So just by choosing that option, it also means by
NOTE CONF
choosing that option, you can always do your work anywhere,
anytime.
NOTE CONF
If you're on your local computer, you've got the Dev
Containers.
NOTE CONF
Locally, you don't you can always jump on a code
space and see it there.
NOTE CONF
This is the way of the future for development environments.
Basically, that those who aren't this way already will will
NOTE CONF
be this way already.
The only thing that stops me using this all the
NOTE CONF
time is that you can't do graphics very well through
Docker.
NOTE CONF
Well, you can, but it's a hassle, and we don't
like to have hassles when I'm teaching so here.
NOTE CONF
In this course, we're not doing any graphics.
It's all text console based stuff.
NOTE CONF
So it's perfect.
You can see it does take a while to build
NOTE CONF
the code space.
This is what it looks like the first time you
NOTE CONF
try and do this.
Just sits there going cos it's gotta get the darker
NOTE CONF
image of the virtual machine.
It's gotta fire it up.
NOTE CONF
It's gotta do all your install steps.
Um, and while you're waiting, you don't get to see
NOTE CONF
your files, but, you know, so back over to our
local one.
NOTE CONF
So please do that makes life nice and easy.
So with this as my development set up, um, for
NOTE CONF
those of you who don't know about which, it's a
nice little Linux command that you can use to find
NOTE CONF
out where in your file system, the binary is like
if you're so on this docker image I'm using to
NOTE CONF
open JDK 11 in that location.
What?
NOTE CONF
I don't need to know where the location is, but
it's sometimes nice to see cos it gives me extra
NOTE CONF
info.
I already knew it was open JDK cos I told
NOTE CONF
it.
But for those who don't aware, there are multiple JDKS
NOTE CONF
you can use out there.
Uh, IB MC a server JDK oracle provide their JDK.
NOTE CONF
And then there's an open source JDK as well.
Uh, the oracle one and the open one normally have
NOTE CONF
feature parody so open GDK will always.
If there's anything you want to do in Java, you
NOTE CONF
can probably do it on open JDK HJDK is missing
a lot of the performance optimisations that Oracle puts in.
NOTE CONF
But for everything that you're likely to do in learning
Java open JK is likely to be the simplest.
NOTE CONF
And it's got an easier install stem or asks for
a bit of information from you sometimes for the install.
NOTE CONF
I just happened to use it because, uh, they provided
a nice docker image for me.
NOTE CONF
And so it was there to go down to version
11.
NOTE CONF
But any version of Java is fine.
The oracle Java is fine.
NOTE CONF
Uh, any other weirdo java you've got is fine, but
you need the JDK, um and then this machine Also,
NOTE CONF
when you're inside this docker container, you've also got all
of the other languages and we're looking at Ruby this
NOTE CONF
week, so you'll be able to see that, whereas on
your local computer.
NOTE CONF
You have to install that and that.
Questions on development environment cool.
NOTE CONF
So here's the line I used to build the locks
script.
NOTE CONF
So building and running the programmes I'm doing by hand
and you'll likely to do that, and we'll provide these
NOTE CONF
when we get to that point.
But I just thought I'd start to show you the
NOTE CONF
published the Lock code.
The sorry, The interpreter that we're writing is in com
NOTE CONF
slash crafting interpreters slash locks, and it's all these Java
files.
NOTE CONF
The class files are mixed in there because of the
way I can part it.
NOTE CONF
But it's just the Java files and either add it
on to mine so I can make it work with
NOTE CONF
Code Runner a few other classes.
So the way my compilation step runs is, it says,
NOTE CONF
Run the Java compiler using the current class path.
Compile every Java file you can see in this directory
NOTE CONF
and compile every Java file you can see in this
directory.
NOTE CONF
And that will cause all those Java files to be
compiled into class files and kept in the same directory.
NOTE CONF
So there they are cos I've run this already and
then I also say Take all the class files that
NOTE CONF
you find in this directory, but who knows what a
class file is?
NOTE CONF
I'll just ask before you know somebody knows.
Yes, it's compile a Java file.
NOTE CONF
It's the original source code.
When you compile it, it turns into a Java file.
NOTE CONF
So that's the executable when you're in Java land.
But you get one for each class to make a
NOTE CONF
single bundled executable.
In Java land, you take all the classes you have,
NOTE CONF
bundle them up and you tell it which one to
start with.
NOTE CONF
So this is all the classes we have, bundling them
up and putting them in a jar file and telling
NOTE CONF
it which one to start with, Um, and to tell
her which one to start with, you have to use
NOTE CONF
this manifest.
You You're not gonna have to worry about this when
NOTE CONF
you're owning your own.
But, you know, well, you won't have to worry about
NOTE CONF
the jar bit.
You'll have to worry about the jab a bit, But
NOTE CONF
just for completeness, here's what the manifest looks like.
The manifest is just a file telling me that the
NOTE CONF
the first, the C, the main class is actually called
this craft interpreter.
NOTE CONF
So once I've got that, I've built a jar.
So that's like a Java executable that I can run
NOTE CONF
entirely by itself.
So I built a two here.
NOTE CONF
You can see I built a locks and AM locks.
That's Matlock.
NOTE CONF
That's my one that I'm building up as I go
along.
NOTE CONF
So this is the one from the text, and this
is the one with all my fancy stuff that I
NOTE CONF
put in.
So once I've got that locks or once I've got
NOTE CONF
that jar, it just happens to be inside my Java
directory.
NOTE CONF
Cos that's where I put it.
I can CD into that Java directory.
NOTE CONF
I can see it with the house to run a
Java programme that's bundled in a jar.
NOTE CONF
You do Java minus jar and then the jar name
and that runs it for you.
NOTE CONF
So that's we are now running a locks interpreter.
By doing that, now I've put that jar for you
NOTE CONF
up line so you can download it.
If you've got any Java later than Java 12, then
NOTE CONF
hopefully Java minus jar locks dot jar will work for
you to run a locks.
NOTE CONF
Interpreter interpreters always I said they ask for an input,
they do some calculation and then they give you the
NOTE CONF
answer.
Then they ask for input again.
NOTE CONF
So here it is, asking for input.
This looks a heck of a lot like a shell
NOTE CONF
prompt because shell prompts are interpreters.
Uh, we've just gone from using the Bash interpreter to
NOTE CONF
now using the Lux interpreter so I can do things.
What happens if I ask for one?
NOTE CONF
It complains, because Lock's statements should all end with a
semicolon.
NOTE CONF
There we go.
One semi colon is a valid lock statement, but it
NOTE CONF
doesn't do anything.
One plus two is a valid lock statement, but it
NOTE CONF
doesn't do anything.
Print One is a valid lock statement, but it does
NOTE CONF
do something.
And so the interpreter does that for me.
NOTE CONF
It prints it to the console.
Print.
NOTE CONF
One plus two is a valid loop statement.
So it runs.
NOTE CONF
It runs.
It means interpreting it.
NOTE CONF
Interpreting one plus two means three printing.
Three means three comes out on the console, and we're
NOTE CONF
just back to the same place, asking for the next
input.
NOTE CONF
Nice.
That's all interpreters do.
NOTE CONF
That's what you're writing.
OK, but now let's learn the locks syntax, because that's
NOTE CONF
what we're ultimately writing our interpreter for, uh, when we
get further into the course.
NOTE CONF
So we better know how locks works, right?
So for that, we are working through this chapter of
NOTE CONF
the book the locks language.
Please make sure you've read through this yourself.
NOTE CONF
I'm just giving, uh, a tour of how it works.
Um, all the there'll be things that I missed that
NOTE CONF
will be here in the textbook.
Make sure you don't miss them.
NOTE CONF
So it's a high level language.
Uh, I don't know if we discussed High versus Low.
NOTE CONF
Probably got a vague idea of what that means.
But remember, we had that on the mountain where the
NOTE CONF
the things on the left, the source code were readable
by humans and the things on the right, well readable
NOTE CONF
by humans and machines.
And the things on the right were readable only by
NOTE CONF
machines, but were perhaps much easier for the machine to
interpret or to run quickly.
NOTE CONF
High level languages sit further to the left lower level
languages sit further to the right.
NOTE CONF
So it's just a position in that trade off between
How understandable is it to the computer versus how efficiently,
NOTE CONF
Uh, to the human versus how efficiently can the computer
in run it?
NOTE CONF
So this is a high level language that wants to
be understandable from our experience.
NOTE CONF
All the languages you're used to Java C well, java
C++ C# python.
NOTE CONF
What other languages have you used?
They're all high level languages.
NOTE CONF
C is also a high level language but considered slightly
less high level than those others.
NOTE CONF
Um, any other languages you've used in you and then
used the low level language, I think.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the JVM byte code is a low level
language.
NOTE CONF
LLVM byte code is a low level language.
X 86 assembler is a low level language.
NOTE CONF
Regular expressions is probably a low level language.
Locks is a language that's dynamically typed.
NOTE CONF
That means, um, well, dynamic.
This is some nice terminology to get straight, so there's
NOTE CONF
strong and weak typing, and there's dynamic and static typing.
The languages you're used to like Java are strongly typed
NOTE CONF
and statically typed, so the the static, dynamic trade off
exists everywhere in computing, and that means static means compile
NOTE CONF
time and dynamic means run time.
So if I say something statically typed, it means at
NOTE CONF
compile time.
I know the type, and if I say dynamically typed,
NOTE CONF
it's not to run time that I know the type
strong versus weak is a decision is a is a
NOTE CONF
trade off As to whether the language is opinionated about
types or not strongly typed languages will only let you
NOTE CONF
use types in exactly the way it wants you to.
Weakly typed languages will let you do whatever you want
NOTE CONF
and doesn't really care if you're using types correctly.
So just saying here that locks is a dynamically typed
NOTE CONF
language.
The way that shows up is that statically typed languages.
NOTE CONF
Normally, when you declare a variable, you have to declare
what type it is.
NOTE CONF
X equals five in dynamically typed languages.
You don't you might write VX equals five or just
NOTE CONF
X equals five.
So we're on the dynamic side.
NOTE CONF
Uh, blessedly, you've probably never had to worry about memory
management.
NOTE CONF
Um, but some languages require you to manage the ra
M space yourself.
NOTE CONF
If you want a megabyte of ra M to operate
in, you gotta ask for a megabyte of ra M
NOTE CONF
to operate in and you've gotta say and it'll tell
you OK, Here's your megabyte.
NOTE CONF
That is, um, manual memory management, automatic memory management languages.
You just create yourself a variable.
NOTE CONF
Build yourself an object.
Do whatever it looks after finding the space for you.
NOTE CONF
That's what you're used to in Java and C++.
Yeah, and probably for most of the C programmes.
NOTE CONF
You're right because you probably don't get to do any
Ming, but that's a that's a more complex issue.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the Mem Memory Management is such a source of
bugs that so that no new programming languages force manual
NOTE CONF
memory management on the use art.
So it's only old school languages that do that and
NOTE CONF
the only one in use.
I guess these days would be C uh so well,
NOTE CONF
probably C++ as well.
C and C++ require manual memory management, Java C# pipe
NOTE CONF
and any of those they all automatic range.
I think here we're doing automatic memory management, and the
NOTE CONF
cool thing about that is that it takes a burden
off the programmer and puts it onto the compiler writer.
NOTE CONF
We're compiler writers this term, so we're gonna take up
that burden of memory management.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna write ourselves a garbage collector, and it's really
good to see the internals of a garbage collector cos
NOTE CONF
For most programmers, Garbage Collector is just this mythical thing
somewhere in my computer that completely dominates my performance characteristics.
NOTE CONF
But I don't really understand, Uh, so you guys will
get to understand it.
NOTE CONF
You'll be used to languages that have lots of different
data types.
NOTE CONF
The the primitive data types, like integers, bullions, floats, doubles
characters and then the compound types like strings.
NOTE CONF
And then any objects you might try to make up.
Lock has a smaller set.
NOTE CONF
It's got numbers, not different types of numbers, just numbers.
So everything's really a floating point.
NOTE CONF
It's got bullions, and it's got strings, that's all.
Bullion Strings doesn't have individual characters, doesn't separate floats versus
NOTE CONF
ins or whatever.
But there's also a special value called nil, which is
NOTE CONF
available to it to go in any slot.
Think of it just like Null works in Java.
NOTE CONF
The same thing he's chosen to call it Neil here,
probably so that because he's implementing it in Java, he
NOTE CONF
doesn't want to reuse the Java word.
No.
NOTE CONF
Um, but, um, plenty of other languages use nil for
that concept as well.
NOTE CONF
So values in this language can either be bullions numbers,
strings or nil, and that's it.
NOTE CONF
Nothing else.
Uh, until, like later on, we'll get to objects and
NOTE CONF
classes.
We can build up more complicated values once we'd put
NOTE CONF
support in for classes.
But right now we're just working with those and those
NOTE CONF
alone.
Cool, OK, another bit of background with programming languages.
NOTE CONF
You know, you're used to seeing each line just to
remind you of the terminology.
NOTE CONF
Each line is a statement, but statements are made up
of expressions.
NOTE CONF
So when I wrote 11 by itself was an expression.
Expressions are things that can have a value.
NOTE CONF
Statements are things that do things, so one was a
expression, but one semicolon is a statement because that says,
NOTE CONF
just do one.
But that's doing one doesn't do anything.
NOTE CONF
One plus two is an expression because it couldn't be
a number one plus two.
NOTE CONF
Semicolon is a statement.
One is a expression print.
NOTE CONF
One is a statement print one semicolon is also a
statement.
NOTE CONF
OK, so with that terminology, sort of, we can go
back and he's telling us all the different types of
NOTE CONF
expressions in the language.
And so this is building up right?
NOTE CONF
The values bullions numbers, strings and nil.
Their expressions that don't that just are already ready to
NOTE CONF
go.
When you get one, it's one.
NOTE CONF
It's ready to go.
When I get three, it's three.
NOTE CONF
It's ready to go when I get one plus two.
It's three, but it's not ready to go yet.
NOTE CONF
It's gotta be.
The expressions got to be evaluated until it gets down
NOTE CONF
to its final form.
So we started with the final forms, strings, numbers, booleans
NOTE CONF
and nil.
And now we're moving on to the non final forms
NOTE CONF
of expressions.
So arithmetic.
NOTE CONF
We can add two expressions to get an expression multiply
and divide.
NOTE CONF
Negation is available in this language as well.
Comparisons are available so they'll take two expressions and give
NOTE CONF
you back an expression.
And they'll always give you a bull, an expression, in
NOTE CONF
this case, so it gives you less than less than
or equal to greater than greater or equal to.
NOTE CONF
It gives you double equals and not equals.
He explains that if you try and do a double
NOTE CONF
equals on things that aren't even the same type, it'll
just return false.
NOTE CONF
That's fine.
It's obvious that 314 is not equal to the pi.
NOTE CONF
This is something you might not be used to being
able to do right.
NOTE CONF
Compare things from different types, but in a dynamically typed
language, you can It's just fine.
NOTE CONF
Make that even be OK.
He's got some logical.
NOTE CONF
So we have the arithmetic operators above.
So if we're working with numbers, then we had the
NOTE CONF
comparison operators.
There's a couple more logical operators here, Um, so these
NOTE CONF
ones work on bullions coming in and they're bullions coming
out.
NOTE CONF
So there's the knot operator.
There's the and operator.
NOTE CONF
There's the O operator.
Don't think of these as keywords.
NOTE CONF
Think of these like end up being keywords.
But think of them like operate just like plus or
NOTE CONF
minus plus.
Takes two numbers and give you a number and takes
NOTE CONF
two bullions and gives you a bullion.
He's using the words and and or cool.
NOTE CONF
He explains that they short circuit in this language.
You might not have thought of this before, but in
NOTE CONF
every language you've programmed so far, if you wrote true
or something complicated, the programme never bothered to evaluate that
NOTE CONF
something complicated cos it knew as soon as it saw
the true that the all was gonna be true.
NOTE CONF
You've actually used this without realising it.
If you've ever typed something like if X so you
NOTE CONF
might have written If X equals null and X dot
length great.
NOTE CONF
And three, that's a piece of Java code you might
write we guarding.
NOTE CONF
So we wanna say that X dot length is greater
than three.
NOTE CONF
But we've first got to check that X is not
equal to null and by coding it this way because
NOTE CONF
the end is short circuited if the X equals null
comes up true.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, This has gotta be X not equal to null.
If the X not equal to null comes up true,
NOTE CONF
it won't try and evaluate the second half which is
lucky cos that would cause an error So short circuiting
NOTE CONF
is actually quite important.
It actually goes right back into the fundamentals of programming
NOTE CONF
that you cannot avoid short circuiting somewhere in a language
and all the imperative languages we create put the short
NOTE CONF
circuiting on the boolean operators and off we go, there
are three things a language needs to be able to
NOTE CONF
be true and complete the names variables it needs functionals
and an eight short circuiting next up is the discussion
NOTE CONF
of precedence.
Uh, you will have thought of this before, but maybe
NOTE CONF
not attach to the word precedence and grouping This is
when I've got multiple operators chained together.
NOTE CONF
How do I know which one goes first?
So the language designer has to set that precedent.
NOTE CONF
You're just like, oh, in mathematics division goes before edition.
But it's not in mathematics.
NOTE CONF
It's in, it is in maths.
But when you're programming it, the programming language designer said,
NOTE CONF
division goes before.
Plus, it was smarter than to do that.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise they confuse everyone.
But you've also got to say, does and go before
NOTE CONF
or does not go before.
Like every single operator, you've got to say which ones
NOTE CONF
go before which other ones and then for the ones
that, uh, end up being on the same level, like
NOTE CONF
plus and minus.
You have to say, you should do the left one
NOTE CONF
first or the right one first.
So you for every kind of operator, you've got to
NOTE CONF
define all those things which are the order of precedence.
And what is the order of grouping once I've run
NOTE CONF
out of precedent to work with.
So he describes what he is.
NOTE CONF
He just does it normally left to right.
It's the ones you'd expect.
NOTE CONF
He's not using any fancy operators for staff to guess
what he's gonna do.
NOTE CONF
And so those are all the expressions how to make
values.
NOTE CONF
Now you know how to make values and make values
out of values and value values.
NOTE CONF
How do you do things?
So the things that you can do in this language
NOTE CONF
are You can print something.
Um, all statements have to end with a semicolon for
NOTE CONF
the interpreter to be able to find them, so that
won't be unfamiliar to you.
NOTE CONF
You can pack multiple statements into one statement by putting
curly braces, top and bottom.
NOTE CONF
This will be very familiar to you, but it's a
bit more fundamental here.
NOTE CONF
He's saying, Look, you're saying print one plus two is
a statement, but so is, uh ah miss the semicolon.
NOTE CONF
So is print one plus two.
That's a statement as well.
NOTE CONF
It's a statement made up of one other statement, and
then I can do print one plus two semicolon print
NOTE CONF
four semicolon.
What he's saying here is that this is actually a
NOTE CONF
single statement because I put the blocks around it made
up of two other statements.
NOTE CONF
OK, cool.
So we can bundle statements together with curly braces.
NOTE CONF
The next kind of statement we have is a variable
declaration and a variable assignment.
NOTE CONF
We got both this one's variable decoration by itself, and
then this one is variable declaration with assignment again, they
NOTE CONF
have to finish with semicolons.
We don't use the type.
NOTE CONF
We just say bar some examples.
You can do an assignment after you've declared.
NOTE CONF
That's fine as well.
I don't know who knows how to pronounce that word
NOTE CONF
someone does.
If you do, then I know your favourite Disney movie
NOTE CONF
Bayonets.
It's not your your favourite.
NOTE CONF
Nobody knows.
Yeah, mayonnaise.
NOTE CONF
They are the things that whats her name makes for
the Southern Bell.
NOTE CONF
That's a famous recipe.
Famous mayonnaise.
NOTE CONF
It's a type of, uh, doughnut thing Princess and the
frog control flow is available.
NOTE CONF
Ifs work exactly the way we expect.
Wires work exactly the way we expect, and four loops
NOTE CONF
work exactly the way they do in C and C++.
Very nice functions work exactly the same way.
NOTE CONF
But notice that, um, when we define a function because
we're in a dynamically typed language We don't have to
NOTE CONF
say what it returns and the keyword he's using to
introduce the function is fun instead of death or void
NOTE CONF
or something.
And you don't have to say what type each the
NOTE CONF
parameters are and there may or may not be a
return line.
NOTE CONF
You don't have to say what it's returning.
You don't have to say whether it returns anything, but
NOTE CONF
if there is a return line, it will return something.
OK, now the next interesting thing, which is something you
NOTE CONF
won't have seen before is this first class functions.
So there were I mean it.
NOTE CONF
What, Lazar, in Java, a first class function is a
function that can be treated like any other variable.
NOTE CONF
And he's demonstrating how that works here.
No, that demonstrations a bit.
NOTE CONF
Nah, I might demonstrate it another way later.
The idea is that functions that can be defined with
NOTE CONF
the fun keyword functions can be called if you put
their name and then some parentheses.
NOTE CONF
But if you just put the name without the parentheses,
you're just talking about the function, and you think I
NOTE CONF
don't wanna run it yet, But this is the function
I'm talking about, and you can put that in a
NOTE CONF
variable.
You can pass that to another function.
NOTE CONF
And when that function wants to finally run that function,
it just puts the parenthesis after it.
NOTE CONF
And off it goes, I I'll say that through a
demo.
NOTE CONF
Now they're called closures here.
Um, so the different names for first class functions are
NOTE CONF
first class functions closures, Landers, funks they all mean the
same thing.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I like to use first class function because the
word closure is a little bit about how it gets
NOTE CONF
implemented, whereas programmers only care about how you can use
it.
NOTE CONF
So for the first class functions, you can use them
just like any other variable.
NOTE CONF
So that's why I like to call them that, Uh,
you can do local functions in locks as well, so
NOTE CONF
you can put a function inside a function, and then
ultimately there's some classes which we won't be playing with
NOTE CONF
just yet.
He shows, um I mean, I'll probably leave this to
NOTE CONF
you to to go through with the class and stuff.
Um ah, maybe we'll see time wise.
NOTE CONF
Um, classes are implemented in locks as well, and that's
quite fun implementing the classes.
NOTE CONF
I guess Let's do it quickly.
They they cut.
NOTE CONF
They work the way you normally expect them to work.
So you don't have to put a fund in front
NOTE CONF
of all the functions.
Um, the constructors are a special function called in it.
NOTE CONF
Rather than using the same name as the class.
It's a fun.
NOTE CONF
The function's gotta be called in it.
It implements inheritance using the the less than operator.
NOTE CONF
So instead of saying, extends another class, you just say
less than another class.
NOTE CONF
But the key interesting thing about his version of uh
is that it follows the JavaScript type of inheritance called
NOTE CONF
prototyping inheritance.
You're used to class based inheritance.
NOTE CONF
So with a class based inheritance, you define a class.
And then every time you write new in that class
NOTE CONF
name, you get an object of that class.
Yeah, with prototype based inheritance.
NOTE CONF
It's good.
There are only objects, no classes.
NOTE CONF
Each individual object may contain states and methods and objects
directly inherit from each other rather than from some class
NOTE CONF
definition.
So instead of having a class hierarchy and then objects
NOTE CONF
hanging off it, the objects just end up in a
hierarchy.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, the original object on languages were prototype based, and
then classes came along.
NOTE CONF
Well, I guess C++ probably popularised classes.
And then everyone copied C++.
NOTE CONF
But, um, the original OO language small talk was prototype
based JavaScript, which is probably the second most popular OO
NOTE CONF
language these days is prototype based.
Um oh, no.
NOTE CONF
So he doesn't do prototype based.
He does class based instead.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
He explains prototype classes and then says, uh, actually, no.
NOTE CONF
Everyone ends up reim implementing classes anyway, So I'm doing
it with class based.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Which is why I was confusing myself thinking, Hang on,
NOTE CONF
that that that foundation looked like a class based one.
And I was trying in my head to retrofit prototypes.
NOTE CONF
OK, cool.
So he does a class based inheritance instantiation inheritance, uh,
NOTE CONF
now standard library.
We spoke a little bit last week about runtime.
NOTE CONF
You know how I said, um, languages get bundled up
with a bunch of other code.
NOTE CONF
It's called a runtime.
If it all goes round in one binary, it's called
NOTE CONF
a virtual machine.
If it's paved off somewhere else.
NOTE CONF
Um, the standard library is the thing that's always, always,
often beefs up your run time.
NOTE CONF
Um, he doesn't have much of a standard library.
Sorry, standard Library is just things that the compiler defines
NOTE CONF
for you so that you don't have to define them
yourself.
NOTE CONF
And he's got basically nothing.
Got a print and a clock, and I think that's
NOTE CONF
it.
What's in the standard library is quite important, though you
NOTE CONF
can't So, for example, there's no read in this.
You can't read user input in locks, and there's nothing
NOTE CONF
in the language that you could retrofit to read from
the user.
NOTE CONF
Cos it's not in the standard libraries just a restriction.
You want your standard library to have at least enough
NOTE CONF
that you can do everything.
And, uh, we're going to implement read at some point
NOTE CONF
as a experiment.
OK, let's do a bit of locks just for the
NOTE CONF
fun of it.
Um OK.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I wanted to show you, actually, the interpreter versus
compiler version, So I'm in the lock interpreter right now.
NOTE CONF
I just put things in, and it won't let me
do a function definition over multiple lines because I can
NOTE CONF
only give it one line at a time, So I'm
gonna have to do it in one line when I
NOTE CONF
send things to my interpreter Fun F.
We return three.
NOTE CONF
OK, accepted that.
That was a statement that defined a function.
NOTE CONF
And then I can So and that was a statement
that ran through.
NOTE CONF
But running food didn't do anything.
But if I print the run of food, it prints
NOTE CONF
through OK, uh, nothing to say it was a bar
bar equals fu.
NOTE CONF
This is me using Foo as a first class function.
F is a function, but because they didn't put the
NOTE CONF
parentheses in all this is done has said, Oh, the
function F which was defined The name Fu is now
NOTE CONF
also defined with the name bar.
So as soon as I take that thing that was
NOTE CONF
attached to food and put parentheses around it, then it
runs.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna make a locks programme Now.
I believe I made a locks directory over here.
NOTE CONF
I did, but there's nothing in there yet, so let's
just put some of those things that I did in
NOTE CONF
there.
Let's do a bar.
NOTE CONF
X equals one plus two.
Let's print X.
NOTE CONF
You notice I tend to put the parentheses in print
even though, uh, the locks description said print can be
NOTE CONF
done like this.
Um that's a a habit of mine.
NOTE CONF
They both work, so let's not worry about it.
Then let's do fun food now because I'm now in
NOTE CONF
a file.
I can use multiple lines and maybe I'm gonna print.
NOTE CONF
Well, let's let's have that taken an argument.
I This is gonna print the numbers from a down
NOTE CONF
to zero or down to one.
If a is less than or equal to zero, then
NOTE CONF
return else.
So this is mostly Java syntax, right?
NOTE CONF
I print I and then recursively call Fu with a
minus one.
NOTE CONF
So this is me using Recursion to write a function
that hopefully is printing the numbers.
NOTE CONF
And then I'll say, OK, F five.
So here's me writing my locks in a script that's
NOTE CONF
useless to me Over here on the interpreter on the
Interpreter.
NOTE CONF
I have to go and do these line by line.
And when I got to line four, I'd have to
NOTE CONF
jam all these into one line, which works just fine.
If I take out the new lines, it's all fine.
NOTE CONF
The syntax tells me everything I need to know, and
that's actually a good point to know.
NOTE CONF
The new lines here don't mean anything they're just used
for the human.
NOTE CONF
I know that the statement is finishing because there's a
semicolon there.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I'm gonna show you how to use lock
as a compiler.
NOTE CONF
Well, it's still an interpreter, but I'm doing it file
at a time.
NOTE CONF
So I controlled C or controlled D to get out
of there.
NOTE CONF
And so I showed you that I was using java
minus jar locks dot jar to start up the the
NOTE CONF
repel.
I should have been using the phrase repel.
NOTE CONF
That interpreter was repel a re eval print loop here.
I'm gonna send it an entire bunch of instructions in
NOTE CONF
one go through a file.
All I gotta do is give it the file name.
NOTE CONF
Um, so if I just put the file name in
here Oops.
NOTE CONF
I gotta go dot dot slash locks slash demo.
Then it takes in all of those lines and runs
NOTE CONF
them all.
So I printed three because I asked it to print
NOTE CONF
X.
Then it defined the function F.
NOTE CONF
And then it ran the function F with five.
So I got 54321 and I was done.
NOTE CONF
So now you know you can write your locks code
in a locks file, and if you just pass that
NOTE CONF
into the jar, you can see what it does.
But if you run that jar without anything, it fires
NOTE CONF
up the re eval print loop so you can do
things one at a time.
NOTE CONF
Let's see what happens if I write an infinite function
function through.
NOTE CONF
So OK, I've not tried this before so that that
defined a function food didn't run it.
NOTE CONF
That was what that was.
Me just using the name food, which is perfectly fine.
NOTE CONF
And but it doesn't run it yet.
And then I pass in the arguments and it dies.
NOTE CONF
It died very, very quickly.
Let's see what it died on.
NOTE CONF
Do I have it at the top?
No.
NOTE CONF
OK, so what it's died on is a stack overflow
in Java.
NOTE CONF
Um, and you can just see it's running the same
things over and over.
NOTE CONF
Cool, Cool, cool, Cool, cool, Cool.
So I'm just getting this giant stack of function calls
NOTE CONF
that the interpreter was doing internally.
OK, not unsurprising, but it did happen quite quickly.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, and now I crashed right out of locks
with that.
NOTE CONF
That's fine, because these arrows came from Java, not from
locks.
NOTE CONF
Let's notice those differences.
When I did one by itself, this was the locks
NOTE CONF
interpreter telling me No, you got your syntax wrong.
And so it gave me a relatively nice error telling
NOTE CONF
me which line it was on if I tried to.
I wonder what happens if I do.
NOTE CONF
Um, a plus B gotta print these things always, Uh,
and you don't have backs and in jeopardy.
NOTE CONF
You can't use your arrow keys.
I plus the OK, so when I do a string
NOTE CONF
and I can, um, add them together, it looks like
it concatenates them.
NOTE CONF
I don't remember reading that in a documentation that might
have been in there, but I just tested it by
NOTE CONF
experimentation and another experiment.
What happens if I try?
NOTE CONF
And there we go.
So here's another locks error.
NOTE CONF
It's telling me, um, here I tried to add a
number to a string.
NOTE CONF
Locks is telling me that No, that's an error.
The upper ends must be either two numbers or two
NOTE CONF
string.
Um, but then the other error that I got was
NOTE CONF
that Java error because it wasn't the locks interpreter noticing
an error and telling me it was the locks interpreter
NOTE CONF
getting broken?
And so ultimately, the J Cos remember there locks interpreters
NOTE CONF
running inside Java.
Ultimately, the JVM eventually finds the error and spits out
NOTE CONF
all those, uh, Java errors.
So when I see the Java errors, it means I've
NOTE CONF
really broken my interpreter.
Probably an error in the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
When I see these other errors, it means, Oh, I've
just done something that's not OK in locks and lock
NOTE CONF
has discovered it in his telling questions.
OK, go have fund writing locks programmes Um and you
NOTE CONF
should spend time writing them because otherwise it'll be really
hard to write an interpret for them.
NOTE CONF
Alright, that's language one done.
Now we can talk about Ruby, but just I won't
NOTE CONF
take a break cos we don't wanna walk out, But
let's just stretch a little bit while we switch languages.
NOTE CONF
It was, and I'll bring up the and this is
me also showing you how to get access to the
NOTE CONF
Seven Languages book.
I think I might have done this before, but I
NOTE CONF
just go to the library and I search and are
you searching?
NOTE CONF
And then I get the full text link and I
follow the full text link.
NOTE CONF
It's this full text link.
Oh, my God.
NOTE CONF
And then I got to go.
You gotta remember we're not in Macquarie University, so I
NOTE CONF
got a institution not listed.
Know that one there?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
And then And we have to do this every time.
NOTE CONF
Cos we're not just gonna go download a PDF of
it, cos that would be nasty.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I know that, Uh, already a user, that's why.
Ok, uh, I don't think that will be the case
NOTE CONF
with the students, OK?
Did you pay for a subscription or something?
NOTE CONF
So bugger it.
I'm not gonna do that because I'm running out of
NOTE CONF
space.
I'm just gonna load up the dodgy PDF.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's a different one.
That's a different one.
NOTE CONF
OK, I don't have a dodgy PDF for this one
yet.
NOTE CONF
I better go get it.
If I sign into the library, does it work better?
NOTE CONF
I can't sign into the library, can I?
A lot, uh, that maybe the one, it just takes
NOTE CONF
me to be all those.
And then I get back to here and I'm an
NOTE CONF
institution not listed, and I'm already a user, and then
it wants me to sign in.
NOTE CONF
So I do try it here.
And well, it's remember the password.
NOTE CONF
So that's a good sign.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
No, that means you sort of signed up for a
trial.
NOTE CONF
Na na na, anyway.
I mean OK, so we are on to Ruby.
NOTE CONF
OK, now, when you get to the classes this week,
you should see the depth of the kind of questions
NOTE CONF
we're gonna ask you about these languages of the week.
Um, this is a slight trickiness of the course.
NOTE CONF
You know, I teaching Ruby that could be two courses
by itself, but at the same time, it's one week
NOTE CONF
of this course.
So how deep should you go?
NOTE CONF
Well, I told you just to do Day one and
day two of this chapter not to worry about day
NOTE CONF
three.
Uh, what was it?
NOTE CONF
D two and D.
Three of the chapter.
NOTE CONF
Anyway, two parts of it.
And not to worry about the last part.
NOTE CONF
And then I'm gonna What you tend to get are
conceptual questions where there was a concept explained in the
NOTE CONF
chapter that then I'll ask you a follow-up explanation of
or you'll get questions where a bit of ruby code
NOTE CONF
is shown that doesn't use anything that wasn't shown in
the text.
NOTE CONF
And you'll be asked to answer again a conceptual question
about it.
NOTE CONF
Maybe what does it output?
Um, but it's mostly about comparing.
NOTE CONF
So So he decides that Mary Poppins is a good
personification of Ruby.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, this this quote is the reason why, because
a spoonful of sugar makes the medicine go down.
NOTE CONF
Ruby is full of what we call syntactic sugar.
Synthetic sugar is where a language doesn't have a brand
NOTE CONF
new concept, but it's got a really nice text format
for you to operate it.
NOTE CONF
And Ruby's got a lot of nice formats.
The thing about I've been back programming Ruby again and,
NOTE CONF
uh, the guy actually bring the the textbook brings us
across going well.
NOTE CONF
Ruby is such a fun language to programme in, and
I can't really tell you why.
NOTE CONF
It just is, uh, so Ruby Programmers tend to all
programmers of every language tend to be quite strongly attached
NOTE CONF
to their language.
But Ruby more than anything, uh, friction.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, friction free.
That's true.
NOTE CONF
It's got just enough of the good fun concepts without
going too deep into them that you have to worry
NOTE CONF
about the hard parts.
That's one way I like to describe it.
NOTE CONF
So Ruby doesn't have first class functions, but it does
have blocks which get you 90% of the way to
NOTE CONF
first class functions without having to do a bunch of
other stuff.
NOTE CONF
I'll show you what they how they work.
So on my virtual machine, I've got Rubik.
NOTE CONF
Now I can do which Ruby and I got a
user in Ruby.
NOTE CONF
But in most cases, Ruby also got a repel.
So we normally, um, in work with Ruby in the
NOTE CONF
repel the repels called IRB for interactive Ruby something.
And once I go in, I get the same thing
NOTE CONF
I can type some ruby code in.
I think this one's a little bit smarter than the
NOTE CONF
other one.
Yeah, it lets me do multi line definitions.
NOTE CONF
So once I tell it, I'm defining a function.
It goes OK, and I'm gonna indent you a little
NOTE CONF
bit.
So, um, give me the rest of the function, please.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, it's a accepted that function food, and then
I can then run food to get through.
NOTE CONF
So I've already demonstrated a couple of ruby things here.
One is that functions are defined with de not fun.
NOTE CONF
The next is the blocks.
Just automatically start with an indent.
NOTE CONF
Well, actually, blocks just automatically start, um, in the right
place cos you always start a block at the end
NOTE CONF
of an end.
You always start a block.
NOTE CONF
At the end of a function definition, you always start
a block.
NOTE CONF
So it just does that for you.
Um, with with an indent to be smart and blocks
NOTE CONF
always finish with an end.
So whether this was an if or whatever, I would
NOTE CONF
just finish off the block.
I'm currently on with an end.
NOTE CONF
So no cooling races, but lots of ends.
Uh, the next thing, actually, is it?
NOTE CONF
Let me define this function without any parameters, and then
let me call it without any parameters.
NOTE CONF
Uh, Ruby's actually, that's one of the trickier things about
Ruby.
NOTE CONF
Functions can have zero parameters or no parameters.
Separately.
NOTE CONF
Thing if I put two parentheses on defining a function
that doesn't take take zero parameters.
NOTE CONF
If I put nothing, I'm defining a function that doesn't
even take parameters.
NOTE CONF
What the heck is a function that doesn't take parameters?
It's variable.
NOTE CONF
There really is no difference between a function that takes
no parameters and a variable.
NOTE CONF
Let me define the exact same thing.
I think I do.
NOTE CONF
VA, No, Let's go.
I'm always forgetting syntax.
NOTE CONF
OK, so you get the history of Ruby.
Maybe I'll talk about that a little bit as well.
NOTE CONF
I'm just trying to jump to a bit of code
that defines a variable property guy.
NOTE CONF
You just do it.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
OK, so food here and bar here are conceptually identical.
There are three letters that equals three.
NOTE CONF
The difference here is that down here, I defined it
with a simple syntax up there.
NOTE CONF
I defined it with a slightly more complex syntax.
Why would I ever want to use the one above?
NOTE CONF
Well, you know, sometimes you write bar equals, you know,
three plus X mod five.
NOTE CONF
Well, what if What if the stuff you need to
do to work out bar is actually really complex?
NOTE CONF
It's 10 lines.
Well, you could just do it like that.
NOTE CONF
You can, def, it.
And you get those full 10 lines and you just
NOTE CONF
return it at the end so your variable definitions can
become as complex as you want, because you get that
NOTE CONF
cool syntax for doing it?
That's very nice.
NOTE CONF
So we don't really have functions without premise.
We really have variables defined using the functions index.
NOTE CONF
Very cool.
The history of Ruby is, uh, interesting one as well.
NOTE CONF
So ruby is a I call it a second tier
language these days.
NOTE CONF
Um, it's being judgmental to put them in tiers, but
because everyone worries about how much a language gets used,
NOTE CONF
it's a big investment to get involved in a language.
So we have to care about whether it's worth that
NOTE CONF
investment and whether the language will survive.
There are thousands of languages out there that are no
NOTE CONF
point learning so that if we think of top tier
languages, guaranteed most places, uh, we want you to know
NOTE CONF
something about them.
Um, and there's no problems getting a job there.
NOTE CONF
Then you're thinking about languages like C, C++, java, python,
javascript.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna maybe C#, um, secondary languages.
Lots of jobs out there.
NOTE CONF
Thousands and thousands of practitioners definitely not disappearing.
But if you're a programmer for that language, you're searching
NOTE CONF
more widely to find a company that uses that language.
Uh, we're thinking of, um Well, there's a bunch of
NOTE CONF
them reviews in that list.
So Ruby was did it ever get to top tier?
NOTE CONF
Maybe.
Maybe not.
NOTE CONF
So it was just created by one guy.
Matt.
NOTE CONF
I don't even I can't even remember his full name.
We just call him Mats.
NOTE CONF
Uh, he's a Japanese guy.
He just wanted a language and made it.
NOTE CONF
And then I just sat there basically doing nothing until
David Heinemeier hansson came along.
NOTE CONF
Um, who fell in love with Ruby as a programming
language.
NOTE CONF
She said, You just do You just and happened to
create a, uh, billion dollar web company called Was it
NOTE CONF
called Base Camp, um, and built it all in ruby.
But then also happened to the the framework that he
NOTE CONF
built in creating this company just happened to be brilliant,
and he published it as Ruby on rails.
NOTE CONF
And it's still one of the better ways to write
a Web application.
NOTE CONF
Even all these years later, David just clued into how
the Web should be described.
NOTE CONF
He clued into how you should be connecting to databases,
and he did it in a way that resonated with
NOTE CONF
a heck of a lot of programmers and and then
everyone piled on.
NOTE CONF
And anyway, I gotta write a Web app.
I'm doing it in rails.
NOTE CONF
It's a million times better.
And so Ruby got popular because rail got popular.
NOTE CONF
Lots of people learned about Ruby and loved Ruby.
And now Ruby and Ra.
NOTE CONF
They're no longer Ruby has a life outside of rails,
whereas for a little while it was just the rails
NOTE CONF
language.
Uh, but the rest of the world caught up to
NOTE CONF
what David had done, and and there are other tools
that work a bit like rails and Java.
NOTE CONF
People don't feel quite so desperate to move over to
another language anymore, because the ideas have come from there
NOTE CONF
to here.
So it's not really these days.
NOTE CONF
If you want to write a Web app, you definitely
use rails.
NOTE CONF
In fact, there's a lot of Python copies of rails
and things like that, but we still have.
NOTE CONF
There's a tonne of companies built on ruby on rails.
There's a tonne of companies still employing ruby programmers.
NOTE CONF
Because of that, we have tooling here at McQuay, built
on ruby on rails.
NOTE CONF
Did I what?
Um, because I was once a ruby and Royals programmer.
NOTE CONF
So what's some other fun things that Ruby does that
we want to know about.
NOTE CONF
Um, I'm gonna keep going back to the book, mostly
just to remind myself to touch on the topics that
NOTE CONF
I know you're gonna read, uh, to a and ask
you about.
NOTE CONF
OK, it's got, uh, string interpolation by default, and you
may not have come across string interpolation.
NOTE CONF
Once you've got it, you'll never go away from it.
String interpolation is the ability to put a variable inside
NOTE CONF
a string using some special notation from your language.
In Ruby, the notation is hash brace and then brace
NOTE CONF
at the end.
And then anything you put inside that brace, it's evaluated
NOTE CONF
before it's put into the string.
It's much nicer than concatenating strings and things like that.
NOTE CONF
Ah, yeah, this is the key thing.
Ruby is a language is a pure object owned language.
NOTE CONF
What what we mean by that is every.
So you're used to in Java, you've got a separation
NOTE CONF
between primitive values and objects.
Primitive values operate one way.
NOTE CONF
Objects operate a different way.
No such difference.
NOTE CONF
In ruby, even primitive objects are even primitive.
Values are objects, four is an object.
NOTE CONF
And because it's an object I can call a method
on it even more than that, Plus is actually a
NOTE CONF
method on the object.
So when I do something like four plus three, I'm
NOTE CONF
actually just pretending to do four plus three.
I'm really doing the four object call the plus method
NOTE CONF
and pass it the value three.
And so the fact that you've got this unifying concept
NOTE CONF
for everything means one less thing to have to think
about.
NOTE CONF
It means you can do kind of fun tricks as
well with methods and stuff.
NOTE CONF
Oh, yeah, You can even find out the methods available
on an object at run time.
NOTE CONF
You can't do that in Java, right?
So I just say four is an object of some
NOTE CONF
variety.
What methods are available on it?
NOTE CONF
And it tells me all of these methods it's using
this, um, symbol notation to give it to me because
NOTE CONF
another thing, Ruby has, uh, that other languages don't have,
which is super cool.
NOTE CONF
Actually, it has this concept of a symbol which is
like a variable, but not a variable generally doesn't vary.
NOTE CONF
And often when it reports something to you, cos Cos
you know function name is not a variable, but it
NOTE CONF
reports to you as a symbol.
Instead.
NOTE CONF
You know that any of these symbols can be called
as methods on that on that object.
NOTE CONF
But you can define your own symbols as well.
So lots of fun things there.
NOTE CONF
Some of them are obviously built in from everywhere you
know.
NOTE CONF
Equals is available everywhere.
Probably object ideas available everywhere.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but some of them are also specific to integers.
I can get the greatest common divider of any integer
NOTE CONF
I can do various Boolean operations.
There's a funny one in triple equals.
NOTE CONF
I wonder what that does.
So at the function.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So plus is in there somewhere?
NOTE CONF
Oh, the food 10, yeah.
F foods in there.
NOTE CONF
What?
Because it wasn't it.
NOTE CONF
So it's there is an integer So food's in there.
Is it Alright?
NOTE CONF
I don't quite understand how food got in there.
I'll get to that.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'll get to the concept.
Too many concepts swinging around my head.
NOTE CONF
Um, this should also give us a clue to the
fact that I can get back all of the methods.
NOTE CONF
Um, I can add methods at run time as well.
Uh, that's called monkey typing.
NOTE CONF
Um, but for monkey patching, I should say, uh, but
so you can have an object that doesn't have a
NOTE CONF
method.
You can add a method to it and then call
NOTE CONF
that method.
There's another special method in here.
NOTE CONF
Is it in this list or not?
I don't think it is because I think it's very
NOTE CONF
special.
Uh, we'll get to that.
NOTE CONF
OK, notice every value is an object.
So, like the the question X less than or equal
NOTE CONF
to four.
That's a bully.
NOTE CONF
And true, that also is an object.
I could ask a question of it because everything's an
NOTE CONF
object.
Anything might be null in ruby.
NOTE CONF
The word nil is used for null.
Uh, puts is used for printing.
NOTE CONF
It has some very nice versions of if it's got
these post versions of if, let me try and demo
NOTE CONF
them.
Just want to get all the way through.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, OK, so I'm gonna demo this by showing you
we're used to the fact that if you got a
NOTE CONF
single line F, I say, let's say I've got you
know, FX Well, let's make XX equals 10.
NOTE CONF
If X is 01 other thing, that everything in Ruby
is an expression.
NOTE CONF
They all get values returned.
So when we did an X equals 10 in locks.
NOTE CONF
Nothing came out of the interpreter, cos that was a
statement.
NOTE CONF
But X equals 10, which is a statement in Ruby
also has a value.
NOTE CONF
So it prints that value for So I wanna say,
uh, if X equals 10, then I wanna put hello
NOTE CONF
and cool.
So I made a little lift statement.
NOTE CONF
It was a single wine, and I had to put
the end in, and it when I finished defining the
NOTE CONF
if it ran it straight away for me.
And if it wasn't good attendance I printed hello, and
NOTE CONF
then the result of that operation was a nil.
So it told me nil cos the the only value
NOTE CONF
it could give to that was nil.
We're used to the fact that often when we have
NOTE CONF
these single line, if we just want to put them
on one line, we don't have to worry.
NOTE CONF
We don't want to worry about the curly braces or
the end.
NOTE CONF
What a hassle in Ruby.
It's got a postfix version for that so you wouldn't
NOTE CONF
write if X equals 10 puts.
Hello, It's already complaining.
NOTE CONF
Right in Ruby, if you want to do a single
line, if you put the if at the end, mhm.
NOTE CONF
And because you've got an If there you can also
put an unless so I do it unless this thing
NOTE CONF
is true.
So I didn't do it that time because X is
NOTE CONF
not a good 10.
And then I did do it because it is not
NOTE CONF
a good tenant, right?
So that post version of the IP is a very
NOTE CONF
cool trick.
And so again, this is the sugar we're talking about.
NOTE CONF
It just a nice way to write it.
But you can think of it in terms of something
NOTE CONF
else.
So I showed you how to define a function.
NOTE CONF
Um ah.
Now every language we come across is going to have
NOTE CONF
a de facto collection type.
This is one of the big downsides of older languages
NOTE CONF
like C, C++ and Java.
They don't have de facto collection.
NOTE CONF
Ah, no, they do.
But the de facto collection's an array.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So the de facto collection in those languages is
an array.
NOTE CONF
Most languages we're gonna look at are gonna have better
de facto collections.
NOTE CONF
The de facto collection in Ruby is a list.
A lot of the languages we're gonna see use array,
NOTE CONF
syntax for lists.
What the heck do I mean by that?
NOTE CONF
How does a list differ from an array?
Well, think of a list like a link list that
NOTE CONF
can grow and shrink.
Things can come in and out, but it's still indexed.
NOTE CONF
0123 if you want to get inside it.
Whereas arrays are fixed size, uh, and very few languages
NOTE CONF
that are built these days default to era era.
They almost always default to listen and movies.
NOTE CONF
One of those it's got some cool syntax for I
think this works.
NOTE CONF
No, that's a range, but it just shows it to
me as zero dot dot three.
NOTE CONF
So, um, this is a literal in the value.
I'm trying to represent 012 and maybe three.
NOTE CONF
So I just typed that in and hoped that it
would expand it.
NOTE CONF
But it didn't expand it because the ranges are literal
in the language.
NOTE CONF
So shall we do a four loop?
Let's see if we can learn how to do four
NOTE CONF
loops.
Now we're getting into classes now.
NOTE CONF
Gotta remind myself how to do four loops and Ruby.
This is also a demo that has a X ruby
NOTE CONF
programme.
I still can't remember everything.
NOTE CONF
So I'm often going to Google to remind myself.
And while not, I'm sure there's a four there it
NOTE CONF
is for a variable name in Do.
That's the one.
NOTE CONF
So when I do a four loop in Ruby, I
do it like a for each loop in Java.
NOTE CONF
So for I in that do and that automatically starts
a block for me.
NOTE CONF
And so I'm gonna put I puts his foot string
by the way and and and didn't do anything.
NOTE CONF
Oh, well, I kind of tug everything as I go.
Well, that's because you've already opened the range at the
NOTE CONF
top of it.
W What?
NOTE CONF
Oh, it's still waiting for more.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Oh, OK.
What?
NOTE CONF
You you You've opened the block and not closed it.
And then you open.
NOTE CONF
Uh, control.
D is not working Control.
NOTE CONF
C is not working.
Oh, I got it back and then I exited.
NOTE CONF
Um, So what?
What Damien's noticing is that because he's got the star
NOTE CONF
here.
When I started, my that star indicates I'm inside a
NOTE CONF
block and I wasn't expecting to have been inside a
block.
NOTE CONF
Then I was expecting that star to appear like it
did when I did the definition of the function.
NOTE CONF
Remember that one?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Well, then we start there.
OK?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
That's exactly what I was trying to do.
NOTE CONF
Uh, back to the book.
I'm gonna shrink this because there's not enough on one
NOTE CONF
page that I'm having trouble reading.
So Day three, we wouldn't.
NOTE CONF
That's the one I left out.
Right?
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna double check.
That's what I said.
NOTE CONF
Or did I include three and not the others?
There's one and two only for Ruby.
NOTE CONF
So Ruby does have an interesting class structure, but I
didn't think we had time to go through that.
NOTE CONF
So we'll leave that, um I do wanna show you
blocks, though.
NOTE CONF
Can't see it right here.
So it might not be in the actual text, but
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna show you blocks anyway.
Because of how cool they are.
NOTE CONF
S.
So what happens in Ruby is that every single function
NOTE CONF
you define has an, um, implicit argument, which is a
block of code.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna make one.
let's make bring in a, uh, bring in a value
NOTE CONF
so I'm making a function called bar brings in a
value and we're gonna do the old trick there.
NOTE CONF
You know, if what we'll do return if I less
than three quarter zero and we'll do puts a and,
NOTE CONF
uh, a minus one.
So the same recursive function again just in ruby format.
NOTE CONF
And then hopefully I can do bar three and get
321.
NOTE CONF
Nice.
Every ruby function has an implicit block argument.
NOTE CONF
Uh, not everyone.
So really, functions can have implicit, implicit block arguments.
NOTE CONF
Um, what that means is that you can pass one
function to another ruby function, but only one and it
NOTE CONF
always has to be the last argument.
But it does give you just enough flexibility to do
NOTE CONF
a pile of really cool things.
Um, because there's only one function that you might pass
NOTE CONF
to another function.
Ruby is able to use a keyword called yield to
NOTE CONF
call that function.
What you need to know is a movie programmer.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'll just try it again.
Def bat, I yield and bat 30, I forgot the
NOTE CONF
argument further up.
That's the problem.
NOTE CONF
Bat three.
The ba ba ba uh, now I'm due back because
NOTE CONF
I know where to find that, right?
About three X puts X.
NOTE CONF
Uh, no, Can't do that.
Can't take any arguments on this one.
NOTE CONF
OK, what the heck just happened?
Let me go back and describe what happened, but I
NOTE CONF
just want to get the syntax right.
So I defined a ruby function called bat bat.
NOTE CONF
Did absolutely nothing.
Took in a number but didn't do anything.
NOTE CONF
It just yielded what the heck is yield Yield is
a keyword that says, whatever function I whatever block I
NOTE CONF
was given, please start running it.
And then that just finished.
NOTE CONF
So it's only job was to take the function that
was given and run it.
NOTE CONF
And then down here is the syntax for how I
called that and give it the one normal argument I
NOTE CONF
was expecting that didn't use and how I give it
a block that is going to yield to So any
NOTE CONF
ruby function can have one of these blocks at the
end.
NOTE CONF
And whenever a yield is in that block, it'll run
this instead.
NOTE CONF
So an example of how that can be useful is
I'm gonna make a function that runs another function a
NOTE CONF
certain number of times so If X has gotten to
zero, I don't have to do anything.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise I'm gonna run whatever function was given to me,
and I'm going to call myself again.
NOTE CONF
I gotta do it with loops because I don't know
how to pass through the yielded function.
NOTE CONF
Hm.
So then it is four.
NOTE CONF
I in, no dot dot no dot dot X do
yield.
NOTE CONF
And and so I think that function we run whatever
block of code got passed in the number of times
NOTE CONF
I asked it to.
So let's try it.
NOTE CONF
Next times three puts four.
Yeah, did it.
NOTE CONF
So what this is allowing me to do is to
find my own looping construct.
NOTE CONF
I mean, it's not giving me anything I couldn't do
before, but you can imagine if you've got some custom
NOTE CONF
looping that has to happen.
You can define the custom looping and send the the
NOTE CONF
block of code each time.
And that block of code can be as complicated as
NOTE CONF
it.
Once I've got it in a single line there.
NOTE CONF
And you on a single line, you use curly braces.
Um, but I could do it on multiple lines as
NOTE CONF
well.
By putting a do instead of a curly brace and
NOTE CONF
then an end, and it ran all of those lines
six times.
NOTE CONF
It ran those four lines six times because, she said,
You can only take one function, but these are so
NOTE CONF
this Here is a single function made up of four
statements.
NOTE CONF
OK, so you can put as many statements as you
want in that function.
NOTE CONF
But you can only have one function I in a
language with true first class functions.
NOTE CONF
I could do the same trick.
And maybe I wanted to run function the first function
NOTE CONF
six times and then the second one in between each
of those six so four times.
NOTE CONF
But I need to take in two arguments.
I would be able to do that in a language
NOTE CONF
of first class functions.
Not in this one.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and so this ends up to be enough to
allow.
NOTE CONF
So I said I said before that it it just
happened to be, um, Ruby on.
NOTE CONF
Ro just happened to be written in Ruby.
It didn't just happen to be written in Ruby those
NOTE CONF
features that we just saw there were what allowed Ruby
on rails to be such a wonderful way to describe
NOTE CONF
Web applications and the key, uh, term I want you
to get here is, um, domain specific language.
NOTE CONF
So we talked about this a little bit last week.
II.
NOTE CONF
I introduced the difference between an API and a language.
API is a bunch of functions that you call language
NOTE CONF
is a bunch of functions that you call that look
like you're writing another language.
NOTE CONF
And Ruby and Rouse ended up being a one of
those bunch of functions that you called looked like another
NOTE CONF
language.
Only because rails had features like methods like dot plus
NOTE CONF
could be called like operators functions could take blocks of
code.
NOTE CONF
And another key feature, um, which is that if you
call a method on an object that doesn't exist, Ruby
NOTE CONF
still runs.
Um, And so by combining a bunch of those things,
NOTE CONF
the rails API was actually way more like a language
and way nicer to use.
NOTE CONF
Um, and so it could really only exist in rales.
And as people brought it to other languages, it got
NOTE CONF
uglier and uglier because those languages didn't have those same
syntactic sugar features that rail had.
NOTE CONF
So let's talk about this method missing thing.
I'm just gonna double check.
NOTE CONF
It's in here because I don't want to waste time
on something.
NOTE CONF
It's not.
Did I make that page go away?
NOTE CONF
Oh, Jesus.
Which one did I make it go away?
NOTE CONF
Ruby Loops?
Oh, no, that's yeah.
NOTE CONF
No, that's fine.
Alright, so there's the code blocks in the yield running
NOTE CONF
review from my file defining classes, writing a mix in
all talk about that.
NOTE CONF
My numerals was in sets.
No, didn't have the thing I wanted to tell you
NOTE CONF
about.
What was he?
NOTE CONF
The method, not known Method must have been in the
third part.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let's, uh, the next thing we will play
with is the hashes.
NOTE CONF
So I mentioned that, um, I mentioned that lists are
better than a raise and that most languages have a
NOTE CONF
default de facto collection type.
It's really a toss up in most languages between whether
NOTE CONF
the default collection type is a list or a hash,
and how it supports both of those covers, most things
NOTE CONF
you might wanna do.
Once you have lists and hashes in the language, you'll
NOTE CONF
find that you don't even bother with other collections much
at all, cos you can just use them for everything.
NOTE CONF
So what's the difference between a list and a hash?
Well, first of all, hashes have multiple names.
NOTE CONF
Hashes can be called associative arrays.
They can be called dictionaries or they can be called
NOTE CONF
hashes.
They all work the same.
NOTE CONF
They are a array or a list, where you control
the index element in a normal list.
NOTE CONF
The Z When you look up zero, you always get
the one at the start when you look up.
NOTE CONF
One.
You always get the next one when you look up
NOTE CONF
two and you always have to use 012 continuous contiguous
numbers to look it up with a hash.
NOTE CONF
But that goes out the window, and you choose what
the first one's called.
NOTE CONF
You.
Choose what the second one's called you choose what the
NOTE CONF
third one's called don't have to be.
Numbers don't have to be contiguous.
NOTE CONF
They can do whatever the heck they want.
So 123 is a list.
NOTE CONF
Oops, I gotta put it in something.
Um, so once I've defined that, then LST zero has
NOTE CONF
to be the first one.
The difference with a dictionary or hash is that I
NOTE CONF
don't just put the values I also must give those
keys.
NOTE CONF
The keys aren't implicitly defined for me.
And in Ruby, the notation for giving those keys is
NOTE CONF
key rocket value.
Let me just check.
NOTE CONF
I've got the come in between, right?
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Two rocket value three rocket.
Done.
NOTE CONF
And the existence of this kind of a data structure
and with along with lists covers you for so much
NOTE CONF
of what you wanna do.
So now, with the hash, If I ask for hash,
NOTE CONF
this will actually give me something.
I think No, no.
NOTE CONF
Hash zero gives me nothing.
Nothing in my hash is indexed by zero.
NOTE CONF
I got something in my ash index by one something
index by two and something indexed by three.
NOTE CONF
And so I've got to use those to get inside.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
And it's getting you back what I want.
Nice.
NOTE CONF
Nothing groundbreaking.
But the extent to which having those built into your
NOTE CONF
language is helpful is huge.
And notice also like there's a bunch of methods I
NOTE CONF
can do.
And a lot of these methods are really useful.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so here's a really useful method.
Each each is one of these methods that takes in
NOTE CONF
a block like the one I this is one of
these custom built loops that I described to you.
NOTE CONF
Let's try and use it.
I think hash dot each is not gonna take any
NOTE CONF
parameters.
I think it's going to take two parameters.
NOTE CONF
There it is.
It did let me explain what just happened.
NOTE CONF
So each was a method available.
But it was one of these fancy methods pretending to
NOTE CONF
be a variable, so I didn't need to put parentheses.
It used the block that I sent it and ran
NOTE CONF
that block for every pair in the hash.
So the B block had to have two arguments because
NOTE CONF
I had to have one for the index of that
pair and the value of that pair.
NOTE CONF
So I called them INB.
And this is, by the way, how you put parameters
NOTE CONF
into blocks.
Use the square.
NOTE CONF
So that block now was gonna get two parameters.
And I said, please, just output the I and output
NOTE CONF
the V.
So I did that output.
NOTE CONF
The I.
The index was the text one, and the value is
NOTE CONF
one.
So this is an example of the power.
NOTE CONF
I don't write a four loop and then access the
hash one by one.
NOTE CONF
I just ask the hash.
Please do this on every element.
NOTE CONF
And no matter what collection I've got in Ruby, I'll
do the same trick.
NOTE CONF
My collection is complicated at once, and I can just
send a block in to have that block happen on
NOTE CONF
every element.
And that's a really nice way to programme.
NOTE CONF
Once you get used to it, you can't go back
to the other way.
NOTE CONF
So that was just one of the fun methods we
saw in here.
NOTE CONF
That was H.
Um, so I'm in.
NOTE CONF
Here's some fun.
Some What does some do?
NOTE CONF
Should we try out?
All right?
NOTE CONF
Can't be coerced into an integer.
So it must be summing up the, um, case or
NOTE CONF
something.
No, but just applying a plus, though you could do
NOTE CONF
that.
I'm gonna have to look up the documentation to find
NOTE CONF
out what some does.
I just asking the name wasn't quite enough.
NOTE CONF
Um, what other ones do you want to know about?
See?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Zip is going to zip it with another hash.
NOTE CONF
We're more complicated.
I.
NOTE CONF
I think we've uh oh.
The two S method is a fun one.
NOTE CONF
That's how um Ruby turns things to strings in in
uh, Java.
NOTE CONF
You'll be used to two string.
So hopefully we'll move you flat.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
I wanna do hash 0.2 S in ruby.
It spits out a string version for me.
NOTE CONF
Um, what was the next thing I wanted to move
on to?
NOTE CONF
That's got a sort method.
Anyway, So a pile of useful methods available on that
NOTE CONF
hash trying to remember the next thing I was gonna
be wanting.
NOTE CONF
Oh, symbols, Yes.
So the symbol is a bit of a it's It's
NOTE CONF
almost a unique thing to Ruby.
I don't see them in other places, and I really
NOTE CONF
love them, but I still find them a little bit
hard to get my head around.
NOTE CONF
Um, so when we did this one when we defined
this hash, it was a little bit awkward that I
NOTE CONF
had to use a string for 12 and three because
I had to put the inverted comma at the top
NOTE CONF
of the inverted comma at the end.
That's not the biggest deal, but I wasn't really thinking
NOTE CONF
of these as strings was I, um I was thinking
them more like I might think of an enumeration or
NOTE CONF
something.
They're the They're the three unique things that are gonna
NOTE CONF
go in there.
I don't care that they're strings.
NOTE CONF
I don't really want to do anything with them.
They just exist.
NOTE CONF
I just want to be able to to find it.
I just wanna know that one's different from two is
NOTE CONF
different from three, and that's really all I need to
know about them.
NOTE CONF
So Ruby's got this idea of something that you really
only need to tell which one you've got.
NOTE CONF
And that's symbols.
And but one, the way most movie programmers think about
NOTE CONF
them is just kind of strings without the string syntax.
So I could do this separately, using the symbol, syntax
NOTE CONF
and symbols, just, uh, prefaced by a colon and just
give me a knee away.
NOTE CONF
And so because 12 and three are different from each
other, I can use them to look into the index.
NOTE CONF
I don't know about you, but it's just much nicer
syntax for me.
NOTE CONF
Um, and I love symbols.
Um, you know, they do things like everything else.
NOTE CONF
You know, when they convert to a string, they just
get back to the original string and but the heaviest.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I don't know I wish I could explain it.
I just hate doing so many times.
NOTE CONF
I'm programming in some of the language.
I just want a symbol.
NOTE CONF
And I have to put a string in instead.
Especially in javascript.
NOTE CONF
I'm always putting strings in where I want symbols.
Um, anyway, I can't think of another language that does
NOTE CONF
that.
Oh, another called Ruby EEL.
NOTE CONF
That's right.
Um, another called Ruby.
NOTE CONF
This is just a coding convention.
But if a method returns a bullion, they'll tend to
NOTE CONF
follow it with a question mark in the name.
That's very nice.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Code box N running ruby from a file just like
NOTE CONF
I showed you with locks.
You know, you can do Ruby line by line, or
NOTE CONF
you can bring in a whole file in one go.
This is the class hierarchy.
NOTE CONF
Ruby works on four inherits from Fix num, which inherits
from integer, integer, integer, integer.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the top level is an object for everything.
Classes themselves are subclasses of module and anything that's an
NOTE CONF
object is a subclass of class.
This is the objects all the way down idea.
NOTE CONF
Everything is an object.
Even class is an object.
NOTE CONF
It can turn your brain inside out a bit unless
you actually degrade to it.
NOTE CONF
I, like practise with a bit.
OK, now we will talk about these attribute keywords because
NOTE CONF
I think that's useful.
Uh, that happens only in classes, though, So let's quickly
NOTE CONF
define a class very simple class when we define fields
of so in dynamic languages like ruby fields inside classes
NOTE CONF
are a design corner.
Fields in the CLI classes work pretty well in languages
NOTE CONF
like Java.
I don't think those class rine into the languages.
NOTE CONF
Strange things start to happen.
So R has an interesting solution here, which is Look,
NOTE CONF
you could I could just give you variables in your
in your class.
NOTE CONF
And sure, you can go down that route.
You can just stick a variable in the class and
NOTE CONF
it acts like a field.
But they brought in two extra keywords ATT R and
NOTE CONF
ATT R accessor.
And you passed in a symbol not a not a
NOTE CONF
variable name, but a S symbol.
And it creates for you it's imagina creates for you
NOTE CONF
a field with that name, a get method for that
name and a set method for that name.
NOTE CONF
Um, but if I just put I can't put attribute
excessive in a string food I can't put attribute excessive
NOTE CONF
in the word food.
I have to put the symbol food.
NOTE CONF
But then once I've done that hopefully on the Mac
class.
NOTE CONF
So how do I make an object of the math
class?
NOTE CONF
I'm losing track of things here.
No, I've lost track of little bit.
NOTE CONF
Matt was just a class.
Uh oh, it's matt.in it, uh, I've forgotten how to
NOTE CONF
create new things in Ruby.
That's new.
NOTE CONF
OK, OK, so now I've made an object from that
math class and X dot foo is a field.
NOTE CONF
I can ask for that field.
But the other cool thing that Ruby does is for
NOTE CONF
the getters and the setters.
You don't have to do X dot get X or
NOTE CONF
get food.
You just do X dot foo And it treats it
NOTE CONF
like a method that gives you back the value of
food.
NOTE CONF
And I don't write X dot set fu.
I just used the old school notation and it treats
NOTE CONF
it like a method called to a set.
So I get the best of both worlds.
NOTE CONF
I get to access it as if it's a field,
but it's only really being accessed through those gets and
NOTE CONF
sets because my gets and sets are simple.
I just use the attribute excess a keyword to make
NOTE CONF
them.
But if my gets and sets were complex, I could
NOTE CONF
go in and control them and write them myself.
Best of all worlds.
NOTE CONF
Look at all these methods.
It gets for free.
NOTE CONF
Here's the F method.
There's the set.
NOTE CONF
There's the getter.
Here's all these other functions I described before that are
NOTE CONF
somehow being attached to everything.
I think I finally worked it out, I think, in
NOTE CONF
the Interpreter.
Every method I define gets attached to the top level
NOTE CONF
object.
Uh, OK, well, I think that's it I want to
NOTE CONF
say about Ruby.
As I said, this is the tour of me talking
NOTE CONF
about things in my coherent way.
The text does its own coherent way.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the questions that we put together for you in
the class and the, uh, very carefully only from those
NOTE CONF
parts of the textbook that we talked about.
So if there was something I snuck into here that
NOTE CONF
wasn't covered in the text, don't stress about it.
If there was something I missed that was covered in
NOTE CONF
the stress text do stress about it.
Um, do you have any other, uh, questions wrap up
NOTE CONF
for today?
Alright.
NOTE CONF
It was relatively short, I guess because, uh, learning locks
was relatively short next week.
NOTE CONF
Um, we're getting into scanning, which will take more time.
And then the week after when we're doing, uh, interpreter
NOTE CONF
plus language, we probably will end up stretching out over
the two hours.
NOTE CONF
But next week I expect it'll just be two hours,
OK?
NOTE CONF
Thank you, everybody.
It was nice to see you.
NOTE CONF
And I'll see you around just before I forget.
I'll check the forums.
NOTE CONF
Oh, there we go.
When we get a manual, you just did get a
NOTE CONF
manual.
That was the manual of how to set up dock
NOTE CONF
with VS code.
Oh, no.
NOTE CONF
There is one extra thing I can tell you about
setting up docker with VS code.
NOTE CONF
Um, you have to put in the extension.
You You you install VS code and then also install
NOTE CONF
the Dev Container Extension as well as having docker installed
on your operating system.
NOTE CONF
And then you get everything you need.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So that was the that was the tour was in
the video and Or you can just go and search
NOTE CONF
on YouTube VS Code de Containers and find someone else
explaining it because there's a million out there, no.
NOTE CONF